Whoopi has lost she is smoking too much
weed I've heard from insiders by the way
that she shows up every day baked that's
what I've just heard I'm just saying
just heard anyway uh here she is and
just yeah it's us it's us that are the
problem not walksters okay go whoopee
this idea of well I'm gonna say it again
most of y'all were asleep
who are you speaking to I'm talking
about all those folks that use that word
woke all the time y'all were asleep
we were never asleep we had to stay
awake watching you
okay so you woke up and you thought oh
my God there's there's lots of women
running among doing things they're not
supposed to be doing and drag queens
everywhere and oh my God people of color
you know you always talk about
the snowflakes look in the mirror y'all
can't seem to handle anything you can't
seem to handle competition from from
Democrats to Republicans you can't seem
to handle the discussions of why people
feel the way they do your idea is to get
rid of everything so stop calling us
snowflakes
be nice Dave try to be nice all right do
I even have to like comment on that like
you guys have been have started a war a
war for children's minds and their
bodies you've tried to racialize
everything you want five-year-olds
watching Disney shows that will teach
white people white kids to be guilty by
the color of their skin you guys have
done this now finally
finally and we have to give Donald Trump
some credit for this Donald Trump broke
the thing so people started seeing it
and then other people culturally and
politically people start getting
involved and start pushing back that's
all they're doing that's all any of us
are doing
[Music]
thank you